[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue d'un point
de vue la seule émission d'actualité en
ce 31 mars où on ne vous parlera pas des
manuels macron et d'un éventuel recours
filmant tout savourer ce qu'on considère
qu'on a rien de suffisamment nouveau ou
intéressant à dire là-dessus bonsoir
jérôme sainte marie
vous êtes politologues sondeurs vous
avez créé votre propre société pôle
inbox et vous avez écrit c'est votre
dernier livre bloc contre bloc la
dynamique du maquereau nice mme bonsant
mathieu souquet êtes consultant à la
tête de votre propre cabinet d'ailleurs
vous aussi vous êtes expert associé à la
fondation jean jaurès et vous avez
conseillé entre autres myriam el khomri
ou elisabeth bornes
je vous propose de revenir sur un
sondage intéressant qui a été publié ce
dimanche mais comme on n'a de
spécialiste avisé de la chose politique
il nous semblait intéressant d'y revenir
publié ce dimanche dans le jdd et sud
radio sondage ifop fiducial qui montre
une
un contraste intéressant entre d'un côté
les idées du rassemblement national et
de l'autre côté celle qu'il incarne
alors commençons par les idées voici
quelques items qui sont relevées dans ce
sondage on a demandé aux français et aux
électeurs du rassemblement national
si la justice était trop laxiste oui à
91% répondre les électeurs du r'n
puisque pas une surprise mais les
français sont presque sur la même
position en étant 81 % à considérer que
la justice est trop laxiste
un autre exemple est ce qu il suffit
d'être nés en france pour être français
c'est non
pour 79% les électeurs du rassemblement
national mais c'est également non pour
70 % de l'ensemble des français
faut-il rétablir la peine de mort en
france oui répondent à 70% les électeurs
du fn et près d'un français sur deux 49%
pour être précis répondent la même chose
l'immigration rapporte tel plus à la
france qu'elle ne lui coûte
il n'ya qu'un tiers des français qui
considèrent que c'est le cas et ce
chiffre baisse encore pour les élections
du r les électeurs pardon du
rassemblement national bref on peut dire
en allant vite que les idées qui sont
traditionnellement celle de ce parti ont
infusé dans la société française et que
en tout cas sur les items que nous avons
gardé
elle recueille un large assentiment est
ce que pour autant le système
présidentiel du rassemblement national
avec un programme et une candidate
marine le pen est adoubé par les
français est bien là c'est beaucoup
moins évident regardez c'est un autre
enseignement de ce sondage des électeurs
du fn passés ou à venir on leur dit mais
est-ce que pourquoi est-ce que vous avez
voté pour ce parti
ils disent d'abord d'un pur pour
protester pour dire qu'on était
mécontent des autres et il y en a
surtout 3% 3 % seulement des électeurs
de l'assemblée nationale qui vote parce
qu'ils apprécient la personnalité de sa
présidente marine le pen
jérôme sainte marie on sait que vous
vous intéressez beaucoup à cet électorat
à ses idées dit populiste
est ce que c'est un problème ce fossé
entre la popularité des idées du
rassemblement national et et le relatif
rejette ont fait l'objet sa patronne
alors je crois que ce sondage
comment dirais-je a un effet un peu en
trompe l'oeil alors il ya quelque chose
qui est bien assurée qui confirmait par
l'ensemble de la production de ce même
institut
l'ifop c'est effectivement la
progression des idées du front national
je me rappelle qu'en mars 2015
un sondage de l'ifop pour le figaro
magazine avait montré que les
sympathisants et l'air ça doit être
peut-être ump à l'époque je ne sais plus
et bien avait sur les aspects
immigration sécurité sur les thèmes que
vous n'êtes cité avec les mêmes
positions que le racing en national est
aujourd'hui pour ça s'est encore élargie
à d'autres électorats et donc
l'hégémonie en quelque sorte idéologique
du rassemblement national sur le pays
est à une chose évidente est confirmée
en sondages alors ce sondage a beaucoup
intéressé en dix ans mais il ya un
contraste ce que vous venez de faire
mais quand on regarde le libérer des
questions on a un peu surpris
moi par exemple comme vous le savez je
regarde souvent les sondages c'est un
peu mon rôle en ce bas monde
et quand j'ai vu 16 % des français
pensent que marine le pen a une stature
présidentielle
je me suis dit mais c'est très très
bizarre parce que j'avais vu un sondage
ifop
il n'y a pas longtemps il ya deux
semaines donc c'est même institut ifop
pour ses news et sud radio
marine le pen a la stature d'un
président de la république alors là
c'est pas 16% ses 37 % marine le pen et
c'est quoi le sens on est pareils ça
nous inquiète c'est un uniforme 56% etc
bref on a quelque chose on a un décalage
incroyable entre ces chiffres là est une
production de l'ifop
il ya deux semaines alors pourquoi parce
que le libellé est très particulier
c'est ses traits d'image s'applique-t-il
plus moins ou autant marine le pen
qu'aux autres responsables politiques et
les 16% c'est pas ce qu'ils nous disent
ce qu elle a une stature présidentielle
c'est qu'il quelqu'un qui nous dit
qu'elle aurait plus une stature
présidentielle que les autres hommes
politiques et même ses 16 % sont presque
curieux parce qu'au fond vous avez un
président de la république qui par
définition une stature présidentielle
donc avoir retenu uniquement la colonne
des plus par rapport à l'ensemble la vie
politique
c'est très surprenant alors d'accord
pour 7
parce que j'ai des programmes et au camp
si vous appréciez la personnalité de sa
présidente marine le pen 3% seulement 2
des électeurs du fn qui ont voté qui
veulent voter ou qui ont déjà voté pour
des candidats ou des listes et rennes
répondent oui là vous à vous il ya
quelque chose ou s'il ya encore un
billet à bahia un billet qui est
absolument évident pourquoi vous avez
c'est une question on demande aux gens
de dire pour quelles raisons avez vous
déjà voté pour les candidats ou des
listes d'url
alors cette question aussi je la compare
à une question de l'ifop
encore une fois publié récemment l'ifop
pour marianne on a un second tour ont
demandé pour ceux qui avaient qui
choisissez marine le pen est pourquoi
vous votez pour elle par adhésion à ses
idées et son programme par adhésion au
par rejet de l'autre candidat 51 ou 52 %
des gens répondaient par adhésion et 48%
par g quand c'était macron seuls 40% des
électeurs de macron disait par adhésion
le reste par rejet de son concurrent en
l'occurrence de sa concurrente
alors pourquoi on arrive à cette
contradiction apparente parce que là
aussi il faut regarder les libérer pour
quelles raisons avez vous déjà voté pour
des candidats ou des listes d'url parce
que vous souhaitiez exprimer votre
mécontentement 29%
donc ça ce côté plus tôt roger le vote
négatif on vote pour quelqu'un qu'on a
pas envie de voter pour les autres on va
voir on va la revoir cette question là
mais quand on regarde les autres items
proposés des items d'adhésion parce que
vous partagez le constat que ce parti
fait pour l'état de la france parce que
vous adhériez aux idées et solutions sur
l'immigration parce que vous adhériez
aux idées des solutions économiques
parce que vous êtes précieux et
personnalité parce que ses dirigeants
semblent les mieux à même de gouverner
bref on a mis sur insolite m la
dimension rejet des autres
mécontentement et on a divisé en quatre
ou cinq items toutes les vannes toutes
les nuances d'adhésion et donc forcément
assez mécaniquement on se retrouve avec
un rejet à 29%
donc effectivement il ya quelque chose
dans la rédaction des questions qui
induit largement la réponse alors je
précise tout seul aux internautes parce
qu'on n'a pas de secret pour vous que on
n'avait pas parlé à jérôme sainte marien
de ceux directement nous lui avons
proposé ce sujet comme avoue matthieu
soupière sans savoir que vous aviez des
réticences sur la la nature même de ce
sondage
mais après tout c'est très intéressant
parce que ça nous
pas sur les chiffres et simplement sa
montre effectivement que la rédaction en
étant comment dirais-je très
particulière en sarre explique pourquoi
il ya une contradiction par rapport à la
production récente du même institut
est ce que vous partagez ce point de vue
mathieu souquet
c'est à dire que c'est peut-être parce
que les questions sont mal posée qui a
une différence aussi forte entre
l'adhésion aux idées du fn et l'adhésion
à sa présidente
alors je suis pas capable de faire une
exégèse aussi poussée que jérôme donc je
ne suis pas sûr d'avoir exactement le
même la même entrée dans le sujet avec
lui ça nous évitera d'être en désaccord
mettront on va traiter le sujet
différemment je vois pas mille
contradiction en fait dans ce dans ce
sondage
d'abord y compris sur l'état de
l'opinion il ya quand même des nuances à
apporter il est incontestable que la
société française c'est au cours des
cinq ou dix dernières années
considérablement droitiser que l'extrême
droite où la droite extrême à gagner
pour partie la bataille des idées que ce
soit marine le pen ou dans son champ à
lui eric zemmour qui est qui qui est en
tête de gondole dans le monde de
l'édition ou en termes d'audimat sur sa
chaîne ses news on voit bien que ces
idées là aussi dans le figaro de ces
idées là on a l'argent derrière chaque
semble scellé votre collègue du figaro
donc effectivement sur l'immigration sur
la sécurité sur tous ces sujets là non
seulement la société française s'est
droitisée mais comme vous le disiez tout
à l'heure
l'électorat de la droite classique est
désormais très proche de l'électorat de
marine le pen
il n'empêche que ce même sondage
rappelle tout de même que la société
française par exemple sur le mariage
pour tous sur lequel s'était déchiré il
y a quelques années on voit bien que
désormais une majorité très confortable
s'est ralliée à cette cause là y compris
chez les électeurs du front national
on peut presque s'en étonner par
ailleurs il est quand même dit dans ce
dans ce sondage également que le
rassemblement national
même s'il a une image qui s'améliore et
pour six français sur dix considéré
comme un parti raciste c'est quand même
pas rien pour six français sur dix ils
constituent une menace pour la
démocratie
donc il est assez logique que celle qui
incarne ce parti là qu'on considère
encore une fois dans 60% des cas comme
un parti raciste et 1 passe et un parti
dangereux que le encore une fois
h2 celle ci ne soit pas un impeccable en
tous points de vue
par ailleurs encore une fois sur marine
le pen
il est quand même dit que c'est celle
qui incarne je dirais même presque de
loin le mieux le parti le rassemblement
national
elle n'a pas vraiment de concurrent à
droite éventuellement marion maréchal-le
pen mais qui pour l'instant est très
éloigné donc il y a pas véritablement de
concurrents en lice possible et on
comprend encore une fois tout ça c'est à
dire que marine le pen à consolider le
socle électoral du front national ça
fait trente ou quarante ans que le front
national est devenu un acteur majeur de
la politique française pendant très
longtemps sans même revenir aux trois
droites de rené rémond il y avait deux
droites en france il y avait une droite
libérale modéré européenne et puis il y
avait une droite souverainiste étatiste
récemment c'était l'udf et le rpr et
puis tout ce petit monde s'est retrouvé
dans l'ump
et désormais il y à bien un clivage à
droite entre une droite de gestion et
une droite jusqu'à présent de
contestation qui pèse plus lourd que la
droite de gestion actuellement et qui
revendique à son tour d'être
gestionnaire donc le procès en
incompétence qu'on ne faisait pas à jean
marie le pen parce qu'il ne revendiquait
pas d'accéder au pouvoir
on est aujourd'hui fondé à le faire à
marine le pen parce que précisément elle
se positionne comme une possible
présidente de la république et deux
points de vue là elle a évidemment pris
très cher au moment du débat qui l'a
opposé à manuel macron mais elle a
remonté néanmoins la pente
elle a remonté la pente c'est
incontestable puisque le socle électoral
qui était le sien en 2017 était à un
niveau inédit et on voit bien
qu'aujourd'hui il s'est apparemment
encore renforcée
réaction de nos internautes celle de
babineau que saluant dans l'inconscient
collectif le patronyme le pen est un
repoussoir pour de nombreux électeurs
isabelle qui considère que la position
de marine le pen sur l'écologie n'est
pas fermée que cela lui coûtera des
votes
réaction de nicole je pense que la
progression du vote et rennes et surtout
dû au fait qu'une majorité de français
ne supportent plus la gauche
et plus que cette progression est plus
dû à cela car la popularité de marine le
pen
la politique de gauche des 40 dernières
années nous dit le petit a stigmatisé le
nationalisme et puis ce sondage qui n'en
est pas un fais attention avec jérôme
sainte-marie parce qu'on voit que il
peut être sévère ça la façon qu'ils sont
envolées donc ce n'est pas un sondage
c'est la consultation de l'élite de ce
pays puisque c'est ce qu'ils sont en
train de regarder point de vue et qui
s'exprime sur twitter marine le pen est
elle la meilleure ennemie du ratio
national
vous répondez oui à 60 % je repose la
question un peu différemment jérôme
sainte-marie est ce que marine le pen
aujourd'hui est un handicap pour son
parti ou pas du tout comme précis comme
candidate à la présidentielle
c'est une question comment dirais je
presque métaphysique parce que si on
l'abordé en général général moi je suis
souvenu de ce point de vue là très
pragmatique du qu'est ce que j'observe
simplement et c'est pour ça que ce
sondage m'avait attiré ma curiosité et
mon esprit critique parce qu'il est
complètement contraire à toute la vague
de sondage de l'ifop ou d'autres
instituts qu'est ce qu'on a actuellement
on a une progression de la popularité de
marine le pen elle est en troisième
position de popularité on souhaite
influence pour l'avenir plus être
prélevés pour être tout à fait précis
dans le libellé pour l'institut bda
troisième position il je crois que dans
un sondage qui a été annoncé sur
internet aujourd'hui à paraître dans le
figaro magazine à sondage kantar
on observe également une progression de
marine le pen qui doit être en 5ème 6ème
position ok très haut pour elle par m me
relever est à découvrir dans le fig mag
de vendredi prochain sachant que devant
eux elle il ya des gens comme nicolas
hulot qui sont un peu hors concours si
vous voulez qu'ils sont un peu
enregistre donc vous avez cette
progression qui est évidente vous avez
une progrès en terme d'image personnel
vous avez tout simplement une
progression dans les intentions de vote
qui a été largement commentée avec des
intentions de vote qui se promène
actuellement entre 45 et 48 % au second
tour donc ça veut dire quelque chose
ceux là où le sondage rappelle une
donnée fondamentale de la vie politique
française qui explique aussi peut-être
l'impression de marasme généralisé c'est
que les deux candidats les plus
probables au vu des sondages pour le
second tour sont deux candidats
fortement impopulaire emmanuel macron
est impopulaire
marine le pen - que certains de ses
prédécesseurs mais enfin quand même il
est impopulaire il même un peu plus
d'après votre sondage à paraître et vous
avez également marine le pen qui est un
qui y est en progression de popularité
mais qui demeure fondamentalement
impopulaire et donc on a de deux
électorats et la différence par rapport
aux autres fois ces quatre fois il veut
la gauche et la droite est donc allé à
la 10e
excusez moi à l'électorat du premier
tour s'additionnaient assez facilement
des électorale y est là aujourd'hui il
ya plus tellement d'allier lit pour l'un
ni pour l'autre et donc on a ces
électorats de premier tour qui aime bien
macro électorat de premier tour de
marine le pen qui aime bien marine le
pen
et puis les autres ils essayent
d'arbitré entre les inconvénients de
l'un et de l'autre
c'est ce qui fait que effectivement
cette question de popularité de marine
le pen là je reprends un peu ce que dit
mathieu soupière avait un intérêt assez
important il ya quelques mois à l'époque
où été testé des solutions alternatives
et tous ces tests ont rêvé
et que pour l'instant on ne voit pas là
et on est quand même plus qu'à un an des
élections
on ne va pas exactement d'alternative
personnel à la présidence du racing en
national de deux éléments de rebond sur
ce que dit jérôme à l'instant en fait
sur l'impopularité de macron elle est
effectivement élevé
il n'empêche que c'est une impopularité
qui est néanmoins inférieure à celle
dont souffrait françois hollande qui lui
permet a priori à ce stade de prétendre
à une candidature et cette impopularité
est également inférieure à celle dont
pâtissaient nicolas sarkozy qui peut qui
peut laisser imaginer que non seulement
ils soient candidats mais
potentiellement réélu ce qui encore une
fois être une première et un deuxième
rebond sur ce que disait l'une de vos
internautes
en dix ans la progression et les sorts
en fait du front national c'est le rejet
de la gauche il y a en tout cas un
élément d'analysé autour de ça le front
national a émergé grâce à jean-marie le
pen sur un fond populiste poujadiste
avec un programme économique et en
particulier fiscal de droite
le problème c'est tel impôt l'impôt et
l'étranger à l'époque et la catégorie
sociale qui s'y retrouvaient c'était en
gros les classes moyennes des employés
des artisans des petits entrepreneurs
s'étaient cette france-là de classe
moyenne à partir du moment où la gauche
est arrivée au pouvoir dans les années
80 le front national a commencé de
progresser de façon significative à
partir du milieu des années 80 c'est le
mans où précisément la gauche à a déçu
les catégories populaires et les a
perdues et marine le pen a réussi à
consolider le socle que son que son père
avait commencé à forger en élargissant
des classes moyennes vers les classes
populaires
aujourd'hui le front national est
solidement implanté et dans les classes
moyennes et des chez les employés et
dans les classes populaires et ouvrières
la question quand même est de savoir si
marine le pen peut avoir l'élan qui lui
permet d'élargir encore ce socle pour
potentiellement devenir majoritaires en
allant grignoter du côté des csp + des
cadres chez lesquels elle est
aujourd'hui 13 à la très très en retard
et chez les retraités
la 3 le troisième étage de la fusée pour
que la fusée soit réellement efficace
c'est celui ci est de ce point de vue là
on ne sait pas encore quel est le
potentiel mais comme le disait jérôme
sainte marie on est encore un an
c'est à la fois peu et beaucoup pardon
de cette banalité parlons d'autre chose
si vous le voulez bien ce sont des
déclarations qui ont fait beaucoup de
bruit en fin de semaine dernière
elles ont été prononcées c'est parole
par audrey pulvar tête de liste
socialiste aux prochaines élections
régionales en ile-de-france et à audrey
pulvar qui ont demandé si elle était
favorable à certaines réunions
interdites aux blancs de type de celle
qu'organise l'unef
elle avait répondu qu'elle était contre
mais que dans certains cas on pouvait
demander aux blancs de se taire certains
ont considéré ça comme une forme de
racisme anti-blancs les réactions ont
été assez beau talent ce qui a entraîné
cette réaction d'audrey pulvar sur le
site internet du monde gay et celle ci a
expliqué j'ai utilisé le verbe se taire
parce que c'est généralement ce que l'on
fait quand on veut réellement écouté
l'autre avant ensuite de prendre la
parole d'aucuns y ont vu une forme de
sommation au silence à tort déclaration
me rappelle un peu vous qui êtes des
gens cultivés un film inoubliable avec
aldo maccione et qui s'appelait tais toi
quand tu parles
enfin je regrette le parenthèses
toujours est il que même la gauche s'est
divisée sur ce sujet sur ce racisme anti
blanc entre guillemets ou pseudo au soi
disant racisme anti-blanc maintenant
apparemment on veut passer à autre chose
écouter anne hidalgo qui est la mère de
bari mais qui est aussi la patronne
entre guillemets ne devrait plus voir
puisque celle ci est adjointe est
clairement anne hidalgo n'aurait pas dit
la même chose mais qu'elle veut surtout
parler d'autre chose regardez ce que
vous auriez dit le riche aux évidemment
main je ne participe plus à ça non je
voulais de bourdin les i je vais en
ville je vous le dis oui je ne veux plus
participer à ça parce que c'est une
situation qui est délétère pour la
démocratie et notamment il ya une
discrimination et une inégalité
fondamentale qui touche toutes les
discriminations
c'est la question sociale et moi je
voudrais qu'on revienne aux vrais sujets
la question sociale les inégalités
sociales c'est ce qui mine aussi notre
république
mathus au caire cette polémique c'est un
dérapage à un accident de parcours ou ça
avait quelque chose quand même de deux
forts alors je les deux mon général il
ya clairement une maladresse ça je pense
que tout le monde de tout le monde en
convient compte tenu de la polémique que
les propos tenus par audrey pulvar a pu
susciter pendant 48 heures 72 heures
ensuite c'est notre système médiatique
qui fonctionne aussi comme ça on imagine
bien c'est ce que cette actualité de ces
derniers jours va être balayé par une
autre et qu'on n'oubliera assez vite
tout ça il ya une maladresse
incontestable et il ya ensuite
effectivement des désaccords à gauche
autour de ce sujet moi j'ai quand même
le sentiment qu'il peut y avoir au moins
un sujet sur lequel la gauche et j'ose
espérer un peu tout le monde pourrait
s'entendre c'est quand même le fait de
rappeler que cette notion de racisme
anti blanc est une fiction absolue quand
je veux dire il n'y a pas de racisme
anti blanc en france il peut toujours y
avoir dans une cour d'école des gamins
qui s'invectivent et qui se disent sale
arabe salle noire sales blancs ça le
français sale juif sale [ __ ] tout ça ça
existe
on a tous très content et des cours
d'école si ça remonte un peu mais on
sait que ce genre de comportement existe
ça ne fondent pas encore une fois une
notion de racisme anti blanc c'est une
fiction absolue c'est une fiction
idéologique il n'y a jamais eu dans
l'histoire intellectuelle de racisme
anti blanc le racisme ça existe ça a été
une idéologie elle est né au 19e elle a
prospéré au 20e
elle a fait des dégâts considérables et
encore une fois le racisme qui dit qu'
il y à des races différentes
fondée sur des caractéristiques
différentes ll n'est immuable etc qui
derrière ensuite injecte pour des
décennies et des générations des
préjugés dans la société ça ça existe
et encore une fois ce ne sont jamais les
blancs qui ont été victimes de ce
racisme idéologiques qui ont été pris
pour cible par ce racisme idéologique et
si derrière encore une fois on regarde
un peu la sociologie il y à bien des
discriminations dans les sociétés dans
la nôtre en particulier et ce ne sont
assurément pas les blancs qui sont
victimes de discrimination donc on
devrait tous à minima s'entendre sur le
fait que le racisme anti blanc est un
concept un peu vaseux et et bien souvent
ce qui encore une fois agite ce concept
là sont ceux qui par ailleurs
a minima minimise la réalité de ces
discriminations dans le pays voilà ça je
pense qu'au moins on peut s'entendre
là-dessus par ailleurs la polémique qui
existe autour de ce sujet me rappelle
celle qui avait eu en fait il ya 20 ans
au moment où on parlait des questions de
parité des questions mixité et des
questions de quotas il y avait déjà en
fait un débat à gauche mais pas qu'à
gauche entre les républicains qui disait
nous sommes universel nous sommes
universaliste et alors même qu'il
s'agissait encore une fois d'égalité
femmes hommes et de féminisme une
elisabeth badinter par exemple
s'opposaient conceptuellement au
principe de quotas au principe de parité
et voilà il y avait à l'époque un débat
un clivage alors ils étaient ils étaient
moins vif et vindicatif moins violent
qu'aujourd'hui parce que on voit bien
que le débat public aujourd'hui et est
chargé d'une agressivité d'une violence
qui n'existait pas il ya vingt ans donc
à la question racisme anti blanc à
gauche
est ce un faux procès question que nous
posons vous réponse est clairement oui
nos internautes ne sont pas tout à fait
d'accord avec vous à 66% il considère qu
accusé la gauche de racisme anti blanc
tu peux être justifiée s'est pas
complètement vrai dire aux mains accusé
la gauche entière non accusé l'unef
oui alors que vole pas su lui dit
comment considérer autrement que du
racisme anti blanc jérôme sainte-marie
mme même question c'est c'est une sorte
de d'incidents passagers ou bien ça
révèle quelque chose de profond autour
de ce qu'on appelle l'indigénisme et en
gros la préférence d'une partie de la
gauche pour sorte de nouveau prolétariat
ou de nouveau exploité que seraient les
personnes que parait-il on appelle
désormais racisées on serait absolument
pas sur la question du racisme anti
blanc je participe pas aussi affirmatif
que mathieu docquiert dans l'histoire on
va dire mais la victime mais voilà donc
ensuite
ensuite vous avez effectivement ce fait
ça dépend des périodes ça dépend des
endroits etc
on va pas rentrer là dedans justement
parce que sinon vous avez effectivement
un incident qui est presque ridicule
parce que là on est en train de pas de
faire l'exégèse de parole très limité
d'audrey pulvar c'est ça paraît
dérisoire si c'était un coup de tonnerre
dans un ciel serein mais ça ne l'est pas
c'est bien le problème c'est bien le
problème c'est que vous avez un
phénomène qui est très présent dans le
monde de l'université
orlov le monde de l'université c'est un
monde de l'école d'une question
nationale
c'est un monde qui est un peu l'humus
sociologique de ce qui reste de la
gauche la gauche a totalement perdu les
catégories populaires par contre elles
prospèrent énormément dans le monde
effectivement de l'éducation au sens
large et ce qui se passe dans ce monde
là n'est pas pour moi interprétable
uniquement comme vous l'avez suggéré sur
le fait que la gauche je chercherai un
prolétariat de substitution ou bien
comme une forme de marxisme renouvelé
c'est comme un joli ça parfois y compris
dans les colonnes du figaro
j'en suis pas tout à fait convaincu
parce qu'en fait c'est un phénomène qui
concerne tout le monde occidental toutes
les universités
regardez ce qui se passe à oxford à ce
que je lis dans vos pages par exemple
c'est pas la trace d'un marxisme
particulier c'est ce qu'on appelle les
études culturelles aux états unis qui
sont en fait un projet qui est
fondamentalement très individualiste
très où chacun en quelque sorte se
victimise par rapport à des attributs
qui l'aurait rappelle là le penser
intersectionnelle j'acquiers des droits
parce que c'est pas des quartiers de
noblesse un peu contraire maintenant
j'acquiers des droits parce que je suis
victime en tant que ceux-ci ou en tant
que cela et puis certains ont un truc
beaucoup beaucoup de discrimination donc
séparés et donc ça leur permet de
demander ensuite beaucoup beaucoup de
davantage compensateur c'est ça aussi
c'est tout ça vous savez a été décrit à
très très longtemps
dans je n'ai pas lu le livre
malheureusement j'ai vu uniquement le
film qui était remarquable
le bûcher des vanités tom wolfe est déjà
ça et ça ce n'est pas quand j'avais vu
ça me paraissait follement exotiques
il tient ça se passe aux etats unis
c'est inconcevable on voyait le travail
dessous tous ces petits entrepreneurs
identitaire qui justement essayer de
contourner les règles habituelles du
fonctionnement la société américaine
grâce
à leur victimisation aujourd'hui on y
assiste
énormément ça joue beaucoup dans vos
universitaire français également ce que
c'est un monde en crise et un monde où
les preuves sont assez peu payés etc
ils espèrent tous enfin certains en tout
cas les plus ambitieux trouver des
postes aux états unis dans ce cas là il
faut créer des études sur le modèle
américain et donc c'est pour ça que bon
ça c'est quelque chose qui nous vient du
mode un monde anglo saxon dont
l'interprétation n'est pas facile mais
qui pour moi ne se réduit pas du tout à
cette histoire de prolétariat de
substitution mais et qui pour la gauche
est par contre un piège
je lui faisais très peu répandu pour la
gauche est un piège fatal pour toutes
les forces de la gauche
la france insoumise l'a tué a pris une
bonne avance il voulait dans le dans le
sabordage en abandonnant les positions
qu'ils avaient pris en 2017
et pour faire le pont avec le sujet
précédent non seulement ça divise la
gauche mais ça crée une impression très
délétère
effectivement dans le pays il ne peut
que favoriser un marine le pen des prix
mathieu st pierre
oui il ya quand même
des dirigeants de la france insoumise
qui ont des déclarations des prises de
positions qui peuvent surprendre
on dit parfois qu'au sein du parti
socialiste il ya des gens qui ont
d'ailleurs quitté le parti comme benoît
hamon qui serait quand même sensible
assez c'est assez
id pardon de type indigènes et sait pas
comment on peut les appeler
donc il ya quelque chose le la gauche y
travaille en profondeur par ce sujet on
abandonne l'idée du concept de racisme
anti blanc a pour en venir mais n'en a
plus tôt 7 7 6 et discrimination raciale
j'ai le sentiment qu'on fantasme un peu
beaucoup un pardon je ne nie pas la
réalité de certaines choses dans le
monde dans le monde de l'enseignement
supérieur mais ces affaires-là sont en
réalité assez résiduelles et je ne suis
pas sûr encore une fois qu'elles
traduisent une lame de fond véritable
enfin je pense même fondamentalement le
contraire et alors il ya toujours dans
les critiques qu'on fait ou en tout cas
dans l'epr qu'on agite le le la
référence à à l'amérique au système
anglo saxon etc on faisait déjà le coup
il ya plusieurs décennies avec encore
une fois les études de genre et le
féminisme universitaire et on disait ces
femmes sont folles alors en france aussi
d'ailleurs bien souvent on se prenait
deux fronts l'ailé radicale du mlf et en
10 s ces personnes sont folles elles
nous font peur et veulent une dictature
et c'est bon en réalité on a vu que il
n'y avait pas eu de difficulté de cet
ordre est au contraire de façon assez
paisible ce qui s'était passé dans le
champ intellectuel dans le monde
universitaire avait permis d'infuser
dans la société de façon relativement
tranquille et aujourd'hui je dirais que
alors que le combat féministe est née
entre guillemets à l'extrême gauche puis
s'est étendu à l'ensemble de la société
plus personne aujourd'hui il me semble
je me sentiment que l'extrême droite est
à la pointe sur les questions d'égalité
femmes-hommes faudrait regarder quand
même mais ça arrange bien apparemment
marine le pen aujourd'hui d'apparaître
comme véritablement une figure féministe
offensive
tout le monde se revendique du féminisme
et le féminisme précisément est une très
grande révolution politique et sociale
du 20e siècle
même une des plus grandes sans avoir
fait de gloire alors vous dites quoique
sans avoir fait le moindre remords il va
se passer la même chose
oui je dis avec les études avec les
réunions jeu juste que quand on a fait
nos plans quand le féminisme s'est
imposé comme mouvement intellectuel
d'abord et ensuite comme mouvement
social assez vite on a contesté on a
critiqué et on s'est fait peur avec les
prétendus excès du féminisme et on joue
encore à se faire peur avec ça
aujourd'hui je ne vois pas je sais pas
exactement où dans la société opère les
dérives du féminisme
on a encore des progrès à faire en
matière d'égalité femmes hommes c'est
sans doute là que le problème est et sur
la question coloniale sur la question
des colonials c'est un peu le même sujet
la gauche s'est emparée de la question
coloniale il ya déjà plusieurs décennies
et aujourd'hui on pointe les excès du
tech du des colonialismes mais encore
une fois j'ai quand même le sentiment
qu'en france ceux qui seront victimes de
discrimination
ce sont les descendants de ces peuples
colonisés et pas les autres
quand on est un footballeur noir on se
fait siffler encore aujourd'hui sur un
stade de foot c'est pas un footballeur
blanc qui se fait siffler par des
supporters noirs
donc il faut arrêter il faut arrêter de
débloquer je pense que on progresse on
progresse sur ces question des
discriminations le racisme recul je dis
quelque chose d'un peu près n'importe
quelle heure le racisme le recul le
féminisme progresse il est vrai en
revanche que la gauche a je pense pas
qu'elle ait déserté la question sociale
mais la gauche est et est empêtré avec
la question sociale précisément à un
moment où les inégalités sociales se
creusent de nouveau dangereusement
c'était la création d'un idéal go jérôme
sainte-marie un dernier mot sur un
sondeur qui nie ça qui est pourtant
censé recueillir des opinions mais moi
ce que je crains le plus en quelqu'un
c'est le comment dirais-je la
fascination pour la subjectivité des
individus et c'est d'ailleurs ces
groupes de paroles sont tout à fait
dangereux parce qu'ayant quand vous
retrouver entre vous quand on a tous des
problèmes
rien n'est plus facile de dire que les
problèmes qu'on a pu rencontrer sont
liées à des formes de discrimination et
qu'ils sont et donc au lieu d'avoir une
approche objective
par exemple les cv anonymes ça fait
quand on fait le test de cv anonyme n'a
pas eu on trouve pas que tout ce que
l'on pensait trouver et donc là on sait
si on s'en remet à la subjectivité
individus on va aller vers une société
de plus en plus atomisé parce qu'on a
tous d'excellentes réaction émotive de
trouver qu'en raison de tel ou tel
aspect on a subi une injustice et c'est
donc là autrefois la gauche dans sa
tradition en tout cas dans l'est
la plupart de ces traditions étaient
plutôt du côté de la science de la
raison et donc de l'objectivation des
choses là aujourd'hui on bascule d'un
subjectivisme qui est très anglo-saxon
discrimination c'est pas c'est pas
uniquement du ressenti les
discriminations ça existe de façon
objective à danser alors là actuellement
c'est tout un débat ça tout en arrivant
pas lourd mais on peut pas tabler by
énorme faute à lui resté la réalité
objective des discriminations sûr que si
on peut la contester
le jeu on va être on va revenir sur ce
sur ce thème et nous ne manquerons pas
de vous interroger là dessus nous
laissons la parole à nos internautes si
vous le voulez bien pour terminer cette
émission à paul qui considère que tenir
ce genre de discours celui d'audrey
pulvar encore aujourd'hui est incroyable
et puis à alain les propos de vrais
pulvar ne font que renforcer le
communautarisme et ce n'est pas bon
voilà nous on se
quitte pour point de vue est pour ce
soir soyez fidèles à figaro live autour
de 20 heures une émission spéciale
de débris après les déclarations du
président de la république sur un
éventuel reconfirme ans et sinon point
de vue ce sera demain à la même heure et
au même endroit
bonsoir à tous
[Musique]